you don't know the power of the dark
side uh here I was thinking I was gonna
add an extra video this this weekend on
Disney's Disney Plus service cuz ain't I
saw one stuff but now they did go and
drop the Star Wars trailer on us so Star
Wars Episode nine the rise of Skywalker
so we have a title we have a trailer we
have some still images and yeah I I
don't think I've actually talked about
Star Wars and Solo came out to be fair I
haven't really wanted to not and like I
want to be clear I didn't like the last
Jedi you can check out my review I'll
put the link to my initial review I did
several videos after that sort of going
to the details of why and I had to do
that because the problems I had were not
the ones that the loudest detractors of
that film were actually shouting about
but you know ultimately my dislike of
that film wasn't what made me not want
to talk about Star Wars the other fans
maybe not want to talk about Star Wars
anymore so I guess it has been long
enough it is it is now due to to start
working up the hype train on this thing
so let's talk about this trailer it
scares the crap out of me and what I
mean by that I don't mean that I think
it looks terrible I don't it doesn't
make me angry but I look at this and
it's a bit of a slightly more extreme
version of the reaction I head to the
Joker trailer which is there are so many
land mines on the path that you have
decided to take for this film at least
the path that's indicated by this
trailer that I really am skeptic
that anyone could dodge all of these
things you've got a lot to get right in
order to stick the landing on this so a
lot of what I'm gonna talk about here is
extrapolation obviously I haven't seen
the film Star Wars in particular
especially these last few films have
been pretty you know tight about what
they have or haven't let us know in
advance so you can't really presume that
you already know what's gonna happen
so I'm not presuming that but I'm still
gonna judge an extrapolate based off
what I've seen and even if I find myself
getting worked up as I talk about some
of this stuff I'm getting worked up at
the ideas that I think are going to
happen I'm not saying definitively any
of this is the case I could be wrong and
if I find my cause I'm getting worked up
about it I hope I am wrong I don't want
to just like the movie I don't like
going to movies I don't want to see you
or not enjoy so that said let's get into
it
I like the opening shot I mean look I
then I don't know if this is gonna sound
weird for people knowing that I don't
like the last Jedi but I like Ray I like
Ray as a character I think she does a
really good job playing her I like the
composition of the shot I like it's that
it's taking a kind of a slow build angle
to it and initially it's just her and
yet here I'm like oh that sounds like a
TIE fighter that be flying really low
though and then you get and go oh yeah
that nope that's a high fighter coming
in real Oh
real fast and that I think that was a
strong opening shot good that worked but
let's get into this thing a little bit
more into the nuts and bolts of it and
the things that I am worried about
we've got voiceover from Luke Skywalker
now it is possible that that is strictly
just being inserted into the trailer
they've done that before they did that
with the with the force awakens teaser
but that's probably gonna leave most
people to presume force ghost and I
think again regardless of your feelings
on the last Jedi not seeing Luke as a
force ghost would feel weird at this
point and be like what the hell so I
think we're we can safely presume we're
gonna get a force ghost
we get to see Lando and honestly just
seeing Billy Dee Williams ooh that light
up the room with that big smile like
okay yeah that's that's gonna be nice
that's gonna be fun and some of the
other little things we get bits and
pieces of this is where I start getting
nervous so we've got the shot of Leia
hugging ray and this shot looks really
over tinkered with like the entire
background seems really overly fuzzy and
you know the clarity's way down there's
like lens flares but if it looks like it
looks like the kind of thing when you
put a lot of work and to cover up the
fact that you're splicing together
footage that wasn't shot to be together
now I've had some friends of mine
suggested possibility that maybe it's a
dream sequence or a flashback or some
way that like maybe and that'll get away
with the presentational bit more but
regardless even if they justify that I
don't like the idea of them having to do
that kind of visual tinkering in order
to make whatever footage they have of
Carrie Fisher actually work so that
makes me nervous we see a little bit of
kylo Ren don't really know what he's up
to he appears to be leading
stormtroopers so I guess we did properly
take over the the new order but then we
start getting to the stuff that's making
me really nervous now look here's here's
my biggest bullet point concern it is
not speculation at this point it's fact
its known it's been a it's been said up
front even since when the film's first
started being developed there was not an
overall story plan there was not a first
film does this third film does this
first film does this second film does
this third film does this and we end
here there was not that plan and that
and that resulted at least I felt in a
really disjointed feel and vibe from
force awakens to the last Jedi which was
not my only problem with the last Jedi
but was one of them because the force
awakens was very much the entire vibe of
the thing was Star Wars just like you
remember it and then the entire vibe of
the last Jedi was Star Wars not as you
remember
and either one of those is fine in of
themselves but to do a new quote-unquote
trilogy and chase the nostalgia bait
with the wood the break all the toys rug
pool it feels like a bait and switch on
fans like if if the whatever the first
entry in this new trilogy was I wanted
that tone just to stay consistent across
it if they'd started with the big rug
pole not Star Wars as you remember it if
episode 7 had had the tone of the last
Jedi I wouldn't have had the same issues
of the last Jedi at least as far as that
element of it goes so now with JJ Abrams
coming back I'm really worried that
we're gonna have like another really
drastic gear shift trying to get back to
what the force awakens was and
regardless of which film you you feel is
better regardless of whether you think
the force awakens is better or the last
Jedi is better that is going to be an
awkward transition just gee getting it
back again it's not gonna flow it's not
gonna feel like a proper trilogy it's
probably gonna leave the last Jedi
feeling like the odd film out again your
feelings about the last Jedi may make
you feel that that's maybe not the worst
thing in the world but I'm still gonna
take issue with it because it shouldn't
happen it should not feel as it should
not feel bad disjointed that
disconnected the title concerns me as
well because okay rise of the skywalker
hmm which skywalker and the big thing
I'm saying here is I swear to god you do
you try and twist oh wait Rey really is
somebody Jesus Skywalker I'm gonna boy
look the idea of Rey being nobody was
one of the few ideas that the last Jedi
did that I genuinely liked I again
connecting the two films it wasn't done
properly because they build it a lot
like she was somebody so then when they
reveal she's nobody it feels like you're
just jerking the audience around for the
heck of it but the concept of Rey being
nobody I liked I always liked I always
ever wanted her to be connected to
somebody so if she turns out to be the
skywalker which certainly the trailer
seems to be built in a way to get you to
feel
yeah that's gonna tick me off but again
to be fair this is speculative and that
first force awakens trailer was built to
make you think Finn was the person who
was gonna be having the force and wheels
in lightsaber turned out not to be the
case so you know I'm not putting a ton
of stock in that but that certainly that
seems to be the vibe in the feel they
wanted to be going for and if it's
accurate that is going to annoy me and
tick me off
and again even if you prefer the idea
that Rey is somebody it's just this
awkward gearshift from film to film to
film and and as much as I dislike the
last Jedi I'm now in those people's like
just regard it it's not canon know it's
there we need to deal with it it did see
here here's the thing the last Jedi as
much as I did not particularly care for
that film it left things in a state
where I was genuinely curious about what
they were gonna do next because it left
things it in a state where well we can't
just wallow in nostalgia they broke
everything it has to go in a new
direction so this one feeling much more
in line with the force awakens a much
more evocative of the past and much more
just sort of looking back and almost
navel-gazing
that that doesn't work coming off of a
film that seemed designed to force
things to move forward as opposed to be
looking back and again as much as I take
issue with the last Jedi as execution
the idea of kind of forcing the hand of
the franchise to move in a new direction
is not an awful one I kind of wish they
had they had done it with something
other than the main saga but they did it
there and I wish they would then take
the baton and go somewhere with it it
reminds me of what happened with the
Alien franchise so like Prometheus was a
movie with a lot of flaws but I thought
a lot of interesting ideas and when I
found out prometheus was gonna get a
sequel I thought god I really hope they
leap off the ideas that Prometheus set
up but instead they made alien covenant
which just brought everything back to
the friggin xenomorph again and they
disregarded all the interesting ideas
that Prometheus laid out with any
and prometheus didn't do all of them
well but they were interesting ideas
that I wanted to see picked up on and
that's kind of how I feel about the last
Jedi so I am afraid that this new Star
Wars that Episode nine is gonna be
analogous to alien covenant trying to
run back to the comfort zone after the
you already blew it up so there's that
going on and then like we literally see
kylo ren's helmet being put back
together I don't I don't want to go so
far as to say that deliberately feels
like it's trying to placate a certain
stripe of fan but that feels like
nothing if not an analogy for the entire
film force awakens introduces you know
basically just a refreshed version of a
new hope last Jedi broke that smashed it
to pieces
and now this one's gonna be like it's
just as good right no you can see the
seams all in it so I I am sitting here
wondering is that helmet gonna end up
being the perfect internal analogy for
what this film ends up being boy I hope
not but maybe and now let's let's get to
the huh the thing at the very end which
set off the biggest alarms the laughs
[Laughter]
that laugh is one of two things neither
of which I would appreciate well it's
one of three and none of these I would
appreciate least offensive option it's
nothing it's nobody it's just pulled
from a previous film to be all
mysterious and tease the fans and
actually is not related specifically to
a character we already know which is
stupid and is typical of JJ Abrams
jerking us around in the lead up in the
marketing I don't like it but it has the
least impact on the finished film next
option its Snoke which is dumb in the
same way that reassembling the helmet is
dumb or turning turn
going ray actually is somebody is dumb
which is that you just I didn't like the
last Jedi bite I took the time I saw it
it occupied my thoughts for a long time
please don't tell me that that wasted
might that you literally wasted my time
by going basically none of that happen
and having Snoke still be alive that you
just kind of feel like you're jerking me
around and it's gonna lend to them we're
making this up as we go feel like really
heavily so I don't like that or option
three its Emperor Palpatine and if
that's the case I King hate it
the idea of bringing back Palpatine
pisses me off so much and again I hope
it's not the case and I would be I would
immediately and happily eat crow if they
do it and find a way to do it that I
actually joy but I cannot think of a
scenario where I don't hate that I tried
talking it out with some friends of
their like well you know I think if they
set it up like he was always behind
everything maybe it'll work and I'm
thinking like no no still no so the idea
of bringing Palpatine back first of all
it's one of the most masturbatory
navel-gazing looking back retrograde
kind of moves that this narrative could
make just bring back the same frickin
bad guy again the epitome of not only
failing to move forward but basically
undoing whatever progress the last two
movies might have had at all there's the
fact that like it absolutely undermines
return to the Jedi which honestly this
new trilogy of films already does a
little bit this thing's already been
living with the vibe of God can't the
heroes just win don't we get to win and
just have a happy ending I know like
whoa it's not that simple in the real
world it's not the real world it's
fantasy it's a film about space wizards
and and dogfights between the stars I
don't I don't care if it's realistic I
should have had my
being at the end of return a Return of
the Jedi they had already got taken away
by the idea of well all the Empire's
resources got co-opted by a new thing
that's basically the Empire Junior so
they already undermined that but if they
literally still have around the person
who the entire point of the end of
Return of the Jedi was to kill him that
was the entire point of the rebellion
was to heal that guy and it turns out
they didn't even manage to do it and
that Palpatine outlived Luke and Han oh
no oh no no no you did not and it just
makes the win tire world of Star Wars
feel so freakin small it keeps coming
back to that it does it does the same
thing that that's soloed the Star Wars
story did everything comes back to the
same handful of characters a galaxy far
far away this feels like a local
neighborhood we keep dealing with the
same people over and over and over again
no matter what goes on in no matter how
much time passes we need to have this
expand if you want this to actually be a
thing now
it's now been said by Bob Iger they're
actually gonna give Star Wars a hiatus
after this one good sit down and don't
force things to come out once a year
figure out what you're doing oh my god I
haven't really checked reactions like I
said I've talked to a few select friends
of mine I don't know if people are
excited at the idea that maybe that was
Palpatine's laughed and they're like oh
everything's right if if that if like
people are genuinely excited about this
I don't know why I don't understand why
because like that kind of moved that
that is the kind of thing Solo did that
is the kind of stupid narrative Lee
unjustified fan wank that Solo had in
abundance and nobody really liked it all
that much because it doesn't serve a
story at all I want to be wrong I want
to be wrong about everything I want this
to feel like it flows naturally off of
the back of of the last Jedi for all the
flaws that last Jedi had I want the
Skywalker to just be the ones we already
know about which basically
as kylo Ren so we're not getting another
surprise oh wait this person actually is
a Skywalker thing going on I wanted them
to build off that last shot at the end
of last Jedi wood that was basically the
invocation the implication that the
heroes could literally be anybody and
come from anywhere
instead of everything revolving around
the same handful of people in this
family I mean I get that the the numbers
August the saga of the stuff the
Skywalker's fine let's wrap it up but I
just I I want to be wrong and sometimes
I am I was wrong about Wonder Woman I
thought it was gonna suck I liked it a
lot I was wrong about Justice League it
wasn't great it was kind of a mess but I
had a lot of fun same with Aquaman I
venom I thought was gonna be one of the
worst things ever again not great but
what was good and it was fun I'm glad I
saw it I want to come away from a Star
Wars movie being glad that I saw it cuz
I haven't had that since rogue one so I
want to be wrong about all of this but
for all the times I just cited or I
thought something wasn't gonna work
and I was wrong there have been a lot
more times that I thought something
wasn't gonna work and I was right so
we'll see Star Wars Episode nine trailer
the music did get to me I'll give it
that
hearing that Star Wars music always does
though whatever your thoughts are about
it oh God part of the reason I haven't
done a Star Wars being a long time is
because the comment sections are such
hot garbage try and keep it in line
people just don't be jerks not to me not
to other people and not to the makers of
the film
okay whatever your thoughts are drop
them down in the comments let's talk
about all but the things to do down
there patreon I'd appreciate it there's
merch there's social media links there's
my PA box give a look at all that stuff
click on things or it you don't have to
it's okay I mean I'd appreciate it but
at the end of the day you're the council
and I'm just running the meeting so
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]